the transport secretary grant shaps is
here in the studio this morning good to
see you
morning so what's happening 25 years
since privatization
now this massive change so what exactly
are we going to see we're going to have
one single familiar organization called
great british railways and
it will run uh all the different aspects
of the
railway in order to bring the whole
thing together it's three years
to the week actually since that
disastrous timetable change in
may 18 where the entire system melted
down and when people said
well who's got control of this the
answer was no one there was no guiding
mind there was no
as the media used to like to say fat
controller looking after the railway
and today's reforms what i'm announcing
takes care of all of that
with a familiar brand great british
railways that i think people will
uh you know be pleased to see having
somebody in control
but one of the key points of
privatization was to separate track and
train
he's saying that completely failed and
bring it all back together
there were many successes not least that
twice as many people are using the
railways that was a big success
of um privatization but it became very
very
fragmented so if you were to say whose
fault is it that this train has broken
down
there are actually 400 people to
allocate the blame within the
organization
who literally you crazy would would have
to work out the size of the bird that
hit the oversight
overhead line that caused the problem
and it would be attributed either to
network rail or to the rail companies
it's just
too complicated but i don't want to go
back to the days of british rail either
we had declining passenger numbers and
railway stations closed and things so
this will be
still with the involvement of the
private sector running the concessions
running the
actual trains but they get paid for
running those trains on time keeping
them tidy and clean
and it will be a single organization
selling you the tickets and
running the timetable but but in terms
of not going back to british reality
again one of the the the supposed
impacts of privatization was that
operating companies would have
um you know their freedom for certain
levels of innovation and what have you
isn't there a possibility here that
great british rail will turn into a
british rail sort of leviathan well
absolutely not what we
uh plan to do with this uh you're right
we want to keep the sort of
the private uh you know initiatives the
capital
the innovation all of that in there but
you've got to have somebody on a railway
which is you know 20 000 miles of track
organizing a timetable organizing the
ticketing
making sure that there's a single body
so you say when something goes wrong you
can say
who is in charge here and there's an
organization and it will be great
british railways
who are in charge so this reform which
is like i see has been widely
welcomed by industry experts this
morning
uh i think is is is overdue i think you
know as a commuter myself i just want
a railway that works i want the
ticketing to be
straightforward and and simple uh and we
won't be going back to the days of
british rail and terrible sandwiches and
all the rest of it
it will be a new organization okay so so
what is the direct benefit for
for passengers then i mean certainly you
want trains to be on time you want them
to be clean obviously i mean that goes
without saying
in terms of the ticketing i mean it is a
bit of a nightmare at the moment
and it's expensive yeah yeah is that
going to change well
that's right at the moment you turn up
at a station there are two or three
different ticket machines you're
supposed to know which one
uh to get if you buy the wrong ticket
you can't use it on this service all of
that
gets simplified and you end up with a
railway where
you buy the ticket it can only be the
right ticket because there's only a
uh uh you know you you're buying yes
great british railways
and whichever route you need to take
you'll be able to take
but actually the other thing is crazy
you stand by these machines they print
out goodness knows how many tickets for
a single journey
why we even got paper tickets i mean it
should be contactless and one of the
great things we'll be introducing
um in june next month are flexible
season tickets
because we know that things have changed
people are working from home a lot more
if you're traveling two or three days a
week uh you'll be able to use these
flexible season tickets
that's only possible because we've
started now on the route towards the
screen i wonder if that is is this going
to guarantee
that it's going to be cheaper though at
the moment if i travel into london i
live about a hundred miles away so if i
travel in on the train
use one particular network one company
it's cheaper than if i get a ticket that
covers all the companies yeah
now is that price and gonna go up to
match the multi company thing or will it
stay at the lower level no well the
great thing is um
depending on how many days you're
traveling in you might well be able to
use the flexible season ticket to do
this you don't have to work out how many
days you're going to be traveling
this week in advance in order to take
advantage of that
and also because it will all be under
great british railways
you can take whichever route you wish to
take if there were different
options and usually to get from a to b
there often can be
different routes to get there because
it's all part of the same thing
one organization setting the fares
setting the timetable
it's a simplification which i think
people will broadly welcome in this
country
okay um sorry about something which
isn't simple which is the the current
state of the covid pandemic
can talk about the indian indian variant
um
because we've still got flights direct
flights coming in from india
there was four yesterday at heathrow why
is that happening
you can't prevent british citizens from
returning home no country can ban its
own citizens
are these all british citizens can only
be a british or irish citizen i should
say or somebody with permanent residence
there's no
it's illegal to come here as a holiday
maker
from uh from a redless country and you
ask about why the flights are direct
well if you think about it
uh if you say the country's on the red
list only british citizens
primarily can return but then you say
there are no direct flights then you're
enforcing a situation uh where people
end up spread amongst many other flights
and making it harder to carry out the
mandatory hotel quarantine which is
a necessity if you come back from a red
country so there's some logic
and indeed we're actually trialing uh
whether it helps to
have everybody in one place on the same
flight come in
and then go straight to government
managed quarantine um
what is confusing you can understand
people being a little bit confused that
the
you know we've seen a 28 increase in
india variant since monday
yet the prime minister then saying he's
more optimistic than he was a week ago
about sticking to the june 21st
ah i think it may just be actually the
dates when these
are reported and not the same dates that
are covered so it will have covered a
period before potentially
but we are seeing and this is what the
prime minister and health secretary both
said yesterday
uh that fortunately the vaccines are
working so the absolute key
is people getting vaccinated and once
they are they are getting covered
against all these variants including
this
indian there are three different indian
variants actually this is b16172
that was causing particular concern but
it does actually
you do actually get protected once
you've had that vaccine
last night when we heard from the health
secretary he said and he did cause a bit
of a smile in the office let me tell you
that he said the government advice on
foreign travel has been
crystal clear even you've got a smirk at
that one well
all i was going to say is i announced it
actually friday a week ago at a press
conference in downing street uh and what
i said is actually if it's an amber or
red country please don't travel
uh for holidays it's for exceptional
circumstances and red is only for
essentially british citizens uh
returning so i can be completely
consistent and say the same thing today
that is the case we we are saying to
people
you know there's a heck of a lot of
hassle involved
in for example an amber country you've
got to take a pre-departure test you
then have to take two further tests
when you come home yet another one on
top of that if you wanted to
have tests to release after five days
you've got a quarantine
people will come to your house to check
your quality i mean it's expensive
it's not we're not at the stage of of
you know saying to people
um go to those places on a holiday in
fact please don't
green lists are for holidays and a
little bit of patience
as the world catches up with our vaccine
program
we'll get more of those countries opened
up as green countries
well and yet people are still going and
and travel agents and airlines and
everybody else are still
selling the holidays and the flights
well look we've moved away from a
situation where everything is
it's banned it's illegal i know we got
very used to this last year everything's
banned and illegal and you know
we're we're moving away from um that and
asking people to apply
a bit of common sense people asking for
guidance the answer is
actually for a red and amber list it's
not for going on
holiday but and you might say well i
have an amber i mean
i've heard this several times and let me
just explain that every country in the
world is put
into the amber category and then when
the joint biosecurity center
look at it they'll either say actually
this country has a particularly good
record they're doing all the uh all the
sequencing they're
they're on top of the problem they've
got high levels of vaccines it's a green
country
or there are real problems here it's a
red country
so the default is amber but amber is not
please go and visit there there's a lot
of cost and hassle
and quarantine required when you go to
those countries
and it is being very strictly enforced
um look
let's wrap back round to transport if if
we can i say
obviously you want more even more people
to go on the trains with this with this
new great british rail and
i know there's campaigns to get people
back on the buses and what have you
at the moment and what about mass
squaring when people are on
public transport should it happen would
you like to see it happen even if it's
not mandated well
right now you do have to wear a mask on
public transport unless you have an
exception
been very very pleased and impressed the
vast majority of people have been doing
it
it's been very good high levels of of
uptake
um that remains in place technically
it's in place until the 21st of june as
we know we'll have a
review that's the fourth stage of the
unlock and we'll be able to say more
about it
at that time but it is in fact the law
at the moment to wear
a mask and that's something that i think
people have just gotten used to doing
people
take their keys they take the wallet
that pick up the mask and they they
leave the home and we're seeing more
people
come back to transport as i say
cautiously but i hope in one direction
we are moving towards
a fuller unlock okay minister good to
talk to you this morning thank you